who are the people that come on and
blow you away i know after this i'm
going to be kicking myself because i'm
going to feel like i i miss people but
um
i will say one of them who's not a
comedian but who i love having on the
show
and is endlessly entertaining to me is
charles barkley
did you bet on that game i did did you
bet like enough to buy a condo
or like what are we talking about here
in what city of space
i would also put shaquille o'neal in
that category they're they're
they're great um david spade
i think is i think when we look back at
the history of talk shows david spade
will be like an
all-time top ten talk show guest his
rhythm is perfect
for a talk show it's just perfect on tv
i come off like a tough guy hard ass
athlete but in real life
but in real life you feel like he's got
a million
great stories it's because he remembers
them and develops them whereas most
people just kind of
go oh yeah that was weird and they just
kind of go on with their day and
maybe they're doing a talk show and they
try to remember what has happened
in their life but to be that disciplined
is is the key i think it's true because
i once talked to steve martin about this
and i said you know you're a great talk
show guest you always come on you're
always funny you're always prepared blah
blah blah
blah he says it's a lot of work and you
don't get paid for it
and he's like i gotta go get a job where
i get paid i can't keep being a guest on
these talk shows and was so brilliant
he's so right
because people don't realize how much
prep a guy like spade probably does
before he goes on these shows speaking
of
martin short is the greatest uh yes i'm
so excited
and it's because you know i'm doing
fallon in two weeks and there's no place
to work out material
well we'll see how it goes always has
great stuff to say
wanda sykes is always hilarious
will arnett is great jason bateman
is always super funny you know who i
think is a great talk show guest
norm mcdonald yeah norm is completely
insane but yeah
i don't think everybody gets norm
mcdonald but i think
norm mcdonald is one of the most
entertaining talk show guests ever
letterman loved uh norm mcdonald
he had a couple of beers before the show
didn't you
yeah he's interesting it's one thing to
be funny and it's another thing to be
interesting dave chappelle obviously is
great at everything
brian cranston is a great talk show
guest
some people are just really good at it
and um some of them don't even work
at it and they're really good at it it's
uh it's it's interesting i guess it's
like
kind of the same thing that makes you a
great dinner guest